how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU in this video today we are going to
be talking about some new information
about the Hawkeye series coming to
Disney Plus and a little bit about the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier series
coming to Disney Plus as well a lot of
people have been wondering what exactly
are we going to get from the Hawkeye
series what exactly is going to be the
story well we know that he's going to be
training kate bishop and we also know
that we're going to see ronan a little
bit more and another thing that we know
is that the Hawkeye series is going to
dive and to cleanse past it's going to
show us what he was like as a child and
how he became Hawkeye and thanks to a
recent report we have an idea about how
that story is going to play out and
about how he's going to run into Kate
Bishop and take her under his wing so be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of my MCU videos also so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a Deadpool Funko pop all you got
to do is subscribe like the video and
leave a comment down below also as we're
talking about Disney Plus shows a lot of
you have been asking me how can you
watch Disney Plus if it's not available
in your country and luckily the answer
is pretty simple you can use a VPN and I
want to thank Nord VPN for sponsoring
this video and helping me bring a
solution to you all I use Nord VPN to
help me access shows that are not
available on Netflix in the US and I
also use them when I travel outside of
the country so I can still watch the TV
shows that I watch at home if you're
trying to watch Disney Plus but you
don't have it available in your country
a VPN will most likely work for you for
example if you do not have a Disney Plus
in your country you can simply download
Nord VPN and then it will connect you to
a remote server and this remote server
will let you access very safely content
that is not available in your country
and this will give you access to Disney
Plus not only will Nord VPN give you
access to content that is otherwise not
available to you but it also protects
your data from going to third parties so
if you purchase a Funko pop you won't be
bombarded on social media with Funko
pops for the next six months so if
you're interested in Nord VPN just click
the link in the description down below
you get 70% off Nord VPN only 349 a
month plus you get an additional month
for free so today's report comes from
Charles Murphy from Murphy's multiverse
comm and he is saying that Jeff
Myers Hawkeye series in the comics may
have a big influence on the upcoming
series and this is what that means
Jeff Lamar's run in 2015 changed the
backstory for Hawkeye now the typical
story for Hawkeye and his brother Barney
are that they have an abusive father and
this story stays true to that as they're
very young Clint Barton and his brother
Barney Barton are abused by their father
their father would eventually die and
they would go on to live in a foster
home in which their foster father abused
them as well
that is until Barney Clint's brother
decides to finally fight back the two of
them then run away and stumble upon the
Carson carnival and here is where the
story begins the Barton boys fall in
love with the carnival but their foster
father shows up and begins to rough them
up a little bit and this is where the
character Duke esna comes in Duke Esme
fights their father off and makes him
leave and he becomes a hero to the boys
and he takes them under his wing he
teaches Clint how to use a sword and he
teaches him how to shoot a bow and arrow
and he quickly realizes that he's got a
lot of skill and shooting and this is
where the story of Hawkeye begins the
kazna shapes him to go on and become
Hawkeye now unfortunately he doesn't
take Clint under his wing he ends up
taking his brother Barney under his wing
but although he does not teach Barney
how to use a sword and he doesn't teach
him archery as well he teaches them how
to become a criminal
Clint eventually finds out and confronts
him about it it doesn't turn violent as
Duke Esme has vowed to never hit Clint
or Barney but unfortunately it does lead
to Clint and Barney going their separate
ways as Clint leaves and this is what
starts him off on the path to become
Hawkeye and eventually down the road
Ronin learning both of the skills
archery and swordsmanship from the
character Dukas name and then as Charles
Murphy also points out there's another
Jeff Lamar storyline with Kate Bishop
and this one is about her past as well
which will most likely see develop in
the Hawkeye series as we're probably
going to see them meet for the very
first time in Jeff Lemm iers all-new
Hawkeye series we find out a lot about
Kate Bishop and how she becomes Hawkeye
in this series we find out that Kate
bishops father Derek is involved in some
criminal activities he specifically
involved with the El Matador and Kate
decides to go and spy on her father and
his criminal dealings and she ends up
trapped in a secret
Haitian she's then kidnapped and held
for ransom by the matador but as it
turns out Clint and the rest of the
Avengers were tracking down the El
Matador the whole entire time and they
show up and end up rescuing her after
Hawkeye and the Avengers rescue Kate
Bishop Kate is fascinated with Hawkeye
she's fascinated how Hawkeye can only
use a bow and arrow but hold his own in
a team of superheroes hawkeye becomes
her hero and she wants to be just like
him and eventually Clint goes on to take
her under his wing and she becomes the
new Hawkeye the two of them would
eventually part ways Kate Bishop being
the new Hawkeye Clint having been her
mentor and a positive father figure in
her life and these stories are the two
stories that will most likely see play
out in the Hawkeye series because we're
not getting an origin Hawkeye movie we
did get an origin story about a lot of
the heroes in the MCU but not Hawkeye
and this Disney Plus show is going to
dive into his origins and the story
about his brother and himself going on
to join the carnival and then going
separate ways is most likely the story
that we're gonna see and then he'll go
on to meet Kate Bishop and he'll train
her to take on the Hawkeye mantle and as
I did mention in the beginning we do
have some Falcon and the Winter Soldier
news Anthony Mackie who of course plays
the Falcon was recently on The Tonight
Show with Jimmy Fallon and he was asked
about filming the series after the
pandemic shut everything down and he
said I'm happy to say that we are not
cancelled we are on hold
we're going back hopefully sometime soon
and finish it up we have very little
stuff to do I'm very happy with it we
have a little more to go back to do but
everybody rest assured it will come out
we're not cancelled this is excellent
news because with the pandemic shutting
everything down it's kind of hard to
know when exactly we're going to get
some of these series and movies with
everything being shuffled around with
their release dates but Anthony Mackie
confirms that they are almost done and
they are going to come out no matter
what this means they are most likely
going to stay true to coming out this
year and this may be our only hope for a
Disney Plus show this year the one
division series should be wrapping up
soon but we know that they have to film
a little bit more as well so it's great
news that we can count on the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier series to release
this year so let me know what you think
about this exciting news what do you
think about Hawkeye's past and what do
you think about Kate Bishop as well
sure to leave your thoughts in the
comments down below and don't forget to
like this video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU for live updates you can
follow me on Twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof